Цей чоловік і жінка - земляки.
Обоє з Луганська. Обоє втратили усе,
що мали через війну. І тепер почали усе спочатку.
Зараз готується поле під посів озимої пшениці.
Тобто, наш з вами хліб.
Селище Новооржицьке, Полтавщина.
На власних полях Віктор поки лише
вчиться обробляти землю
спеціальним трактором.
Не так давно він - ветеран родом з Луганщини -
заснував агрогосподарство.
Ми починали з 3 гектарів,
зараз вже земельний банк налічує 70 гектарів.
Почали читати літературу, відвідувати виставки,
ну і досвід в АТО також допомагає.
Коли в АТО керуєш БТР або БМП,
то воно своє дає -
вже габарити відчуваєш,
на будь-яку вантажівку можеш сісти.
З тракторами є свої нюанси, але все ж таки.
У те, що службу в ЗСУ обміняє
на роботу із тракторами та землею,
каже Віктор, колись би нізащо не повірив.
До 2014 року він був професійним
прикордонником, а у зоні АТО
працював у спецзагоні.
Місто Щастя Луганської області,
Станиця Луганська, Кримське,
Попасна, Лисичанськ, Золоте.
Це починаючи від розвідки місцевості
і закінчуючи вже пошуковими діями.
Тобто були місця, де ми виходили,
ця територія не контролювалася ні нами,
ні формуваннями так званих ЛНР і ДНР.
Після травм від бойових дій
та психологічного виснаження
чоловік пішов зі служби.
Віктор ще не знав, з чого почати нове життя.
Роботи для нього не було.
У 2021-му йому та побратимам
держава надала земельні ділянки як ветеранам.
Свої ідеї для бізнесу Віктор
реалізувати не встиг через початок
повномасштабної війни.
Але за станом здоров’я, чоловік не зміг піти воювати.
Або ти йдеш воюєш, або ти допомагаєш.
Ми допомагаємо, ми забезпечуємо своїх побратимів.
Це техніка, ремонт техніки,
запчастини, пальне - все необхідне,
що було потрібне хлопцям,
ми намагалися забезпечити.
Виторг за той рік – приблизно 70 відсотків –
пішла на допомогу хлопцям.
У планах - розширення господарства.
Втім Віктор все ще потребує знань
у агросфері. Він вирішив піти
навчатися за цим профілем в університет -
а витрати йому покрила держава,
надавши спеціальний ваучер як ветеранові.
Подзвонили, запропонували пройти навчання,
за ваучером, чому б і ні?
Людям доводиться вже
підлаштовуватися під ті робочі місця
і професії в місцях, куди вони виїхали.
Охочих змінити фах, як Віктор,
розповідають у Державній службі зайнятості,
під час війни офіційно реєструють десятки тисяч.
13 тисяч з них вже отримали
навчальні ваучери від держави,
що покривають освітні послуги -
в коледжі або університеті -
на суму понад 26 тисяч гривень.
Отримати документ можуть переселенці,
люди з інвалідністю, особи старше 45 років
та соціально вразливі групи населення.
5 тисяч людей вже точно закінчили навчання.
Наприклад, люди, які переїхали з Донецької,
Луганської областей – працювали на
металургійних підприємствах –
переїхали у області, де немає таких підприємств -
на захід України, Черкащину, Вінниччину.
І їм треба змінювати роботу, професії.
Дуже багато чоловіків знаходиться на військовій службі,
тому для жінок вимога часу
опанувати "чоловічі" професії.
З останнього - багато жінок опановують
роботу на екскаваторах, машинних маніпуляторах,
перевозять вантажі.
Для учасників програми є понад 120
спеціальностей на вибір.
Втім, каже директорка державної служби зайнятості,
дуже популярними серед українців
є запити на опанування соціально відповідальних професій.
На перше місце, до речі, вийшла психологія –
по навчанню. Раніше так не було.
Лідери – психологія, соціальна робота.
Вдих: рухаємося вгору,
обличчя розвертаємо, руки вгорі, ми робимо паузу.
Я арткоуч, фасилітаторка, тренерка
з професійно-емоційного вигорання,
допомагаю людям долати наслідки
стресу та дбати про себе,
дбаючи про інших.
Так віднедавна почала
представлятися Олена.
Вона теж опановує нову для себе професію -
психотерапевта. Сьогодні вона як
менталкоуч проводить заняття з
переселенками, які торік втекли від
війни на Луганщині у Кременчук.
Дії, які допомагають виходити зі стану
страху і тривожності.
Дії дуже корисні!
Уже є наснага щось робити!
І цікавість!
У 2014-му Олена була на місці цих жінок.
Разом з 9-річною донькою вони
застали війну у рідному Луганську.
Боже! Бігти треба! Бігти!
Але ухвалення рішення саме їхати -
це було, коли всю ніч стріляли,
летіли літаки, сирена вила прямо під домом.
Про кар’єру тренерки з візажу,
яку жінка старанно будувала
у Луганську, довелося забути.
Переїхавши до Кременчука,
Олена довго не могла знайти роботу.
Тож, вона долучилася до громадської
організації, яка опікувалася
переселенцями і вирішила розвивати
місцеву громаду.
Аж поки не почалося
повномасштабне вторгнення.
Нібито я зайшла на друге коло!
По тому ж маршруту,
але вже з навичками, я знаю,
як їх використовувати, я знаю, що буде,
я знаю, який проміжок часу мине і що буде.
І це той досвід, який я можу давати тим дівчатам,
які приїхали у повномасштабну.
Тобто, я розумію ті етапи, які вони проживають,
я розумію оцю втрату ідентичності.
"А хто я? А що я? З чого я буду починати своє життя?
І чи починати мені його?
Мені відкладати своє життя і чекати?
Чи жити зараз?"
Кілька разів на тиждень Олена
влаштовує зустрічі з переселенцями,
проводить групові та індивідуальні тренінги.
Також вона займається терапією
з військовими ЗСУ.
А після цього - бере до рук смартфон
і сідає за навчання.
Завдяки ваучеру від держави, Олена здобуває
академічну освіту за спеціальністю "Психологія".
Якщо я копаю, то я копаю глибоко!
Просто на поверхні мені не досить.
Я хочу базову освіту.
Це для мене підтвердження того,
що я професіонал, я на своєму місці.
Якщо я маю академічну освіту,
це професіоналізм саме.
Якщо мене держава підтримує
в такий спосіб, я маю не проґавити цей шанс!
Переселенці, з якими регулярно працює Олена,
зізнаються - пошук профільної роботи
після евакуації з рідного регіону у багатьох
триває вже понад рік.
Інна - родом з Попасної і досі
переживає стрес від пережитого.
Руйнівна сила пішла!
Повністю все… Домівки, все!
Багато людей з дітками виїжджали.
Важливо прожити хоч на щось.
Тому про кар’єру сильно не думаєш.
Є якась робота, ти її робиш.
Моїх послуг не потребують.
Треба перекваліфікуватися,
чимось іншим намагатися займатися.
У державній службі зайнятості
кажуть - перелік кваліфікацій
для навчання за ваучерами
постійно оновлюється, як і зростає
попит на них. Втім, гарантій
працевлаштування проєкт не дає.
Новоспечений аграрій Віктор,
що почав нове життя після служби
на фронті, обіцяє - щойно його
господарство набере обертів,
готовий влаштувати до себе на роботу
інших ветеранів та переселенців.
А ми такі люди! Ми такі люди:
ми шукаємо, де краще, як краще.
Війна, звісно, згуртувала деяких.
Буде дуже багато ветеранів,
які повернуться до своєї праці,
коли це все закінчиться,
будуть працювати в полях.
Головне - це перемога!